[Music]
since time immemorial since we can
remember since forever this is our
ancestral territory it would be
impossible to live in rural Alaska if we
didn't if we were not able to live off
the land Alaska Natives were here long
before Alaska became a state just half a
century ago since then the state's
economy has thrived because of oil but
not everyone has benefited from that
wealth and the promise of oil profits
has created a rift between those who
live off the land and those who want to
profit from its natural resources this
is the story of that divided
[Music]
there's over 227 tribes in the state of
Alaska every territory in the state has
an indigenous nation that has inhabited
that area since time immemorial it was a
very challenging way of life we're
living in 60 below zero for weeks at a
time in the wintertime
no sunlight for large portions of the
year our people were survivors the first
outsiders to come to Alaska in modern
history were Russian fur traders in the
18th century and even though indigenous
people had been living there for tens of
thousands of years the Russians stole
the claim to the land calling Alaska
their own and in 1867 Russia sold Alaska
to the United States for 7.2 million
dollars the whole problem from the
earliest days on was the United States
sort of bought a flawed titled toward
the end of that century more and more
Outsiders came to Alaska either to make
their fortunes or to spread their
religion but with the influx of
outsiders came new diseases that Alaska
Natives didn't have immunities to it was
a really horrific time because we lost
so many family so many people so fast
that there was no place to put their
bodies I mean they just had to pile them
up mass graves from the time of contact
up until about the the early 1920s it
said that we lost 2/3 of our population
by the 1930s Alaska Natives were
experiencing another traumatic loss as
Native children were sent to schools
based on Western education including
boarding schools when they were sent
there if they were wearing their
traditional clothing all their clothing
were was removed and put outside and in
a pile as they went into school the boys
hair were cut to be short they weren't
allowed to speak their language in
situations of my own mother being sent
away for seven years of her childhood
and being told that she can't speak her
language that she's not a witch in
person
that she has to become something than
who she is in order to succeed in the
world today they would come home and
they would be displaced because the
parents didn't know who they were their
parents didn't speak the same language
as their children they didn't know how
to hunt or be able to survive on the
land so there was this huge
disconnection even though I didn't live
through that time I feel like I did it
just was passed down you know I don't
understand why my grandmother doesn't
speak any back to me or you know I don't
understand that but I feel it during
World War two
thousands of soldiers were sent to be
stationed in Alaska and for the first
time Alaska Natives became a minority on
their own land and then in 1958 Alaska
held a vote to become a state or remain
a territory the vote for statehood
passed easily because Alaska Natives
didn't have much of a say but statehood
did not clear things up for who really
owned the land there were some Indian
villages between Anchorage and Fairbanks
that were complaining that the state was
taking their land willie hensley was
only 25 a grad student in 1966 when he
stumbled upon something that changed his
life and the lives of all Alaska Natives
even though the young state was
obligated to protect land where Alaska
Natives lived those boundaries had never
been drawn and so the young state had
started to take the land for itself I
realized that we're gonna lose that land
forever we are never going to get it
back and so as a student I decided that
we had to stop it Willy decided to run
for State House to get the word out and
he helped rally Alaska Natives across
the state to claim their land
senator Hensley of Kotzebue our rallying
cry was a take our land take our life
and it was controversial because we
weren't accustomed to taking on
government we had been encouraged to
obey Authority it took a little bit of
nerve to actually not only say no but
hell no you can't have it as Alaska
Natives organized to claim their land
something happened that got the state in
the world to really pay attention oil
let Alaska's North Slope at Prudhoe Bay
a lot of it possibly the biggest
discovery in history as soon as you had
the discovery of yet another vast
natural resource that could be exploited
in Alaska you had the interest of major
international corporations the state was
in desperate straits I mean they were
financially going down the drain because
the state couldn't afford statehood you
know we had this teeny population no
revenue of any consequence high costs
and they needed that money
you know from oil the oil industry
really just wanted it resolved they just
wanted to make sure they have access to
the oil and and in particular that they
had access to a corridor to build the
trans-alaska oil pipeline in order to
build that pipeline the state needed to
know who in fact owned title to the land
it would cross and so the land claims
argument became front-and-center we
literally had no time we had no money
initially we had no lawyers we had no
communication system and we had to
create structures we didn't even have
institutions we had some very young
leaders who are in the early 20s most of
them many not college-educated for the
next three years these young leaders
including Willie rushed back and forth
to Washington DC at door stepping
congressmen to pay attention to their
cause in 71 it came together all of a
sudden the House passes a version of the
bill the Senate passes a version and it
was in conference on December 18th 1971
the Alaska Native Claims Settlement Act
or anxia was signed into law by
President Richard Nixon Alaska Natives
ended up getting 44 million acres of
land about
10% of Alaska and 963 million dollars to
compensate for the land they lost at the
time it was the largest native land
settlement which for many felt like a
huge success
but not everyone felt the settlement was
fair the Alaska Native Claims Settlement
Act was an illegitimate act that was
forced on our people most Alaskan
Natives did not have a say just a
handful how to say it was sort of
bittersweet because was more than any
other Native American group ever
received out of Congress but still you
know we knew that we were letting go of
a huge amount of our traditional land
holdings as part of the settlement the
land was not transferred directly to
Alaska Natives instead it created Alaska
Native corporations which would own
those 44 million acres Alaska Natives
became shareholders in those
corporations hunters and fishermen and
housewives that we were you know I was
we had to sort of try to think like
businessman just imagine coming from a
little tiny community where your people
don't even speak English and being told
you have a corporation now and you need
to successfully manage this corporation
or you can be overtaken many of these
Native corporations did see big profits
because of oil and mining they worked
with companies like Exxon Mobil VP and
ConocoPhillips
but these are the same industries that
have contributed to climate change
threatening the hunting and fishing
grounds of Alaska Natives the thing
about the Alaska Native Claims
Settlement Act is there was one line
item that said all Alaskan Natives
gave up Aboriginal rights to the land it
was one tiny line this line meant that
Alaska Natives could no longer hunt fish
and gather where they have been doing so
for tens of thousands of years they were
now subject to hunting licenses
restricted areas and designated seasons
they were coerced into signing they were
told this is the best bill that you're
gonna get there simply was no other way
to get control of our space since the
discovery of oil at Prudhoe Bay and the
signing of Inka oil has been the
economic driver in Alaska oil tax
revenue has paid for schools
streetlights and social programs the oil
industry employs a third of the state's
workers it's allowed the state to do
away with sales and income taxes and
it's created the Permanent Fund which
pays each resident an annual dividend of
about $1,000 the trans-alaska pipeline
that one 800 mile steel pipe going
through the middle of Alaska has been
the lifeline for Alaska I mean really
it's created modern Alaska but many
Alaska Natives never saw all those
profits it's still extremely expensive
to live in the villages where many homes
lack basic plumbing most Alaskan native
villages still hunt we still fish we
still gather we have to live that way we
have to have our way of life money is
short term but the land will always be
here for us to provide for us and we
have to care for the land in this next
video we are going to take you above the
Arctic Circle where my people that which
in are fighting to protect one of the
largest and last pristine wildlife areas
in the United States the Arctic National
Wildlife Refuge from oil drilling
[Music]